in the past few years we've seen in
certain circles both right wing and left
wing we've seen a resurgence of
something with the call acceleration ISM
which is the desire to to participate in
the breakdown of society or the
breakdown of structures in order that
something new will occur and so push
things to their extreme so that a new a
new system will occur now this appears
both on the left and the right and many
people have asked me what I think of
this and if I think it's a viable
solution to the problem this is Jonathan
page Oh welcome to the symbolic wheeler
[Applause]
[Music]
and a lot of mean culture and a lot of
the chaotic stuff that we've been seen
coming out of the chants out of the
reddit's the kind of bubbling up of
crazy imagery and you know especially
some recent means that we've seen we've
the idea of acceleration ISM has become
more and more popular and people have
asked me symbolically what I think of it
and what I think if I think it is a
possible solution to the problem of
Western civilization as we see it now um
in order to answer that question we need
to remind ourselves something that I
insist on constantly which is that there
is a deep analogy between the personal
structure and the social structure that
is there's a strict analogy between the
human being and the communities in which
that human person participates and one
of the problems of acceleration ISM is
somehow to think that those two things
are separate from each other that you
could somehow participate in the
destruction of society that you could
somehow accelerate chaotic elements of
society and somehow remain unseen in
yourself from doing that and I think
that it is a very dangerous game to play
because as we want to push certain
factions certain elements that we find
decadent or
elements that we find dangerous for
society in order to to quicken the
collapse of of everything in the hopes
that something better will be born we
are also engaging on that road within
ourselves
it is very few people who can
legitimately rise above the fray and act
could act in that way without themselves
falling into the very things or being
taken into the very things on their own
fringes that they want to encourage on
the fringe of society you know I do
believe that a lot of the things that
we're seeing happen today are a ARRA
playing out of the Christian story I've
often said in my in my videos that
within the Christian story it is
important to see that the death of
Christianity is part of it the death of
Christ is part of the Christian story
and the death of Christianity is part of
the Christian story itself the Christian
story seems to be a a process by which
as Christ says all things are revealed
and for all things to be revealed it
means that we both the wheat and the
tares grow up at the same time means
that as you uncover things you won't
cover both the mysteries and the scandal
at the same time and those two things
are inevitable as the world opened the
world moves towards the resolution of
the Christian story and so I think that
Christ himself put it the most
succinctly when he said that it in his
own coming in the consequences of his
own coming that scandal must happen but
he also then says woe to those by whom
it happens and I think that that in that
statement is the deep understanding that
that it is normal that what we see
around us is happening this upside-down
world the chaos the degeneracy that we
see around us this is something which is
inevitable in the cycles of history and
inevitable in the big story of the
Christian revelation
you could call it but to play a part in
bringing about the the end of Western
civilization to play up out you know
you've seen some evangelicals in you
know in recent times doing things in
order for Christ to return to provoke
the return of Christ this is an old way
of acting you know you saw this all the
way in the Middle Ages where certain
people acted in certain ways especially
during the time of the of the Crusades
in order to restore to bring about the
return of Christ an example of very
strange example of that is Christopher
Columbus himself who who in one of his
ideas was to go out and in order when he
found the the the lost when he found
North America one of his goals that is
not publicly known very well was
actually to find the Garden of Eden and
in and finding the Garden of Eden was
was in his idea was to to bring about
you know the end of time is to bring
about the return of Christ you see
several people have that approach and I
think that it is a the very idea that we
would act in a way to provoke you know a
kind of chaos or to provoke a breakdown
so that you know that the story will
resolve itself I think it is very
dangerous for society and it is very
dangerous for ourselves what we need to
do is to do what Christ told us to do is
to become just to become like Christ to
to emphasize the virtues and to become
little lights and those little lights
you know no matter how dark it gets
those little sparks those little lights
will have enough we need to trust that
they will have enough light to carry us
through the flood to carry us through
the chaos and to be to be little lights
in the uncut into the coming darkness
and and this not only for society as a
whole but for yourself for your own
spiritual development for your family
for those around you if you let yourself
embrace the cynicism that it requires to
be
an acceleration estate will it will have
negative consequences on yourself on
your family and those around you and it
is no matter what we think it is
embracing a kind of nihilism a cut even
if it is not even if you do believe that
by doing so you will bring about some
new order some new thing in the actions
that you pose it is an embracing of
nihilism and and I don't think that most
of us can say above that fray I hope you
enjoyed my discussion in ending I would
like to give a special thanks to matthew
wilkinson matthew wilkinson is a friend
of mine i stayed at his house in fall
when i carved this very large stone
monument and he has written for me this
amazing outro which is based on the
introduction to my videos the russian
eastern overture by rimsky-korsakov but
which is ultimately based on the pascal
him i'm very grateful to him that he did
that for me and you will hear it from
now on at the end of my videos and good
and so guys thanks again for your
attention and i will see you soon
[Music]